serious questions over the way it
operates after a review said that
Britain's largest Force needs a complete
overhaul and tonight Sky News has found
evidence of bad attitudes being applied
to investigations of sexual assaults by
officers in another constabulary in a
special report one serving member of the
humbicide police says that she was left
traumatized by abuse from a fellow
officer
well we'll bring you that report in a
moment but first let's take a look at
what the review by baroness Casey found
today it said that the Met is
institutionally racist misogynist and
homophobic it says a lack of vigilance
towards officers abusing their positions
has allowed predatory behavior to
flourish rape cases were dropped after
fridges broke and destroyed key evidence
and 12 percent of women in the Met said
they had experienced sexual harassment
or assault our home editor Jason Farrell
who's been speaking to two women tonight
who reveal problems with misogyny within
the humbicide police force for a while
seeing a police officer in uniform I'd
have like flashbacks
if something happened to me again I
don't think I'd ever report it this is a
serving police officer so traumatized by
abuse from a fellow officer that she's
questioning her own force of homicide
and her testimony suggests there might
be the need for a Louise Casey style
review into sexism and other failings in
every police force not just London's
Sally says the sexism starts the moment
you arrive
the conversations quickly turn sexual
I was sort of propositioned
you feel like you fresh meat that's the
attitude you feel like fresh meat coming
in
I want to start speak out about it and
start telling people
everyone was like oh yeah he's doing it
to me oh yeah he's done it to me and
it's always the same officers humbicide
constabury was rated outstanding by the
police inspectorate but Sally says when
it became known she'd reported a fellow
officer for sexual violence her
colleagues rallied around him I was
ostracized given the cold shoulder so I
had to be stared at or given dirty looks
they will at school yeah bullies
after the misconduct hearing so after he
lost his job I lost count of the amount
of offices that came up to me and said I
was always being like that really yeah
and he'd been in the job a really long
time
and I thought well why have they not
said anything then yeah he basically had
the same nicknames as those monsters in
the mat
Wayne cousins was nicknamed the rapist
by fellow officers before he murdered
Sarah everard David Carrick a serial
rapist was in the same unit now the
Casey review has found the Met police's
institutionally sexist but does it go
wider Sally says in homicide for example
colleagues knew that one predatory
officer would get vulnerable victims
details from statements to ask them on
dates and you think he was known for
this his full shift would have known why
he was like what's a full shift I reckon
on each team I reckon 20 police officers
and Sky News has evidence of bad
attitudes potentially impacting
investigations Anna alleged as a Teenage
issues being raped by a gang of men who
intimidated her into going back to them
she used what's called a subject access
request to get homicide police records
on herself she found these types of
comments made by officers
if the reports are genuine we have a
very vulnerable victim who keeps putting
herself in danger this is a very regular
occurrence the female herself is making
lifestyle choices of her own this victim
doesn't come across as the best type of
witness victim that I've seen
that whole time I was still under Social
Services I was really vulnerable I was
on a protection plan it said how I was
getting strangled I was being sexually
assaulted I was high risk but they never
did anything to stop that it's very much
attention seeker lifestyle Choice says
maybe putting herself at risk is another
thing that comes up so they're kind of
blaming you there's no wonder the case
was never brought to court because
before it's even got there they've
completely undermined it I think they
basically set that case up to fail
in one extract they seem to accept the
alleged attacker story saying the victim
states that she's received injuries and
these have been seen by police officers
the issue that we have is that the
suspect admits to causing these injuries
to the victim but states that these were
with consent as the victim says she
liked it
it is difficult for us to disprove this
and I would suggest the victim is too
undermined in this investigation to take
her word above that of the suspect
I think it's quite disgusting like how
they can say that someone would enjoy
being injured it makes me really angry
Louise Casey's findings have rocked
London's police force but she told Sky
News the problems are likely to be
National should there be a Louise Casey
type review into every other police
force I actually think the answer to
that is yes because I think that what we
have found there are some things there
light vetting like sort of the cultural
issues particularly around race and
around women I think that they are
National issues and I do think we need a
wholesale change of public protection
particularly for women so we need this
across the country a proper delve into
what's going on within police forces I
think that we need a route and Branch
review of policing
after a review Anna's investigation was
reopened and for that reason humbicide
police say they can't comment further
but deputy chief Constable Paul Anderson
said child sexual abuse and exploitation
is a deplorable and condemnable crime
and we're determined to bring offenders
to Justice and hold them accountable for
their actions with regard to Sally the
force says misogynistic Behavior will
not be tolerated adding there is an
existing robust process in place anyone
who exhibits any form of misogynistic or
discriminatory Behavior will be held
accountable for their actions we are
internally communicating with all
officers and staff in regards to sexual
harassment and have launched our knowing
the line campaign to raise awareness and
to fully encourage reports whether
personal or witnessed to be made to our
Professional Standards Department
Sally says she's still proud to be a
police officer but she's speaking out
because she wants her colleagues to make
the changes from within it's now
snowballed into a massive thing
because it's been hidden for so long and
bushed into the carpet that is now a
monster
the Casey review suggests that monster
needs to be exposed and acknowledged
before it can be properly tackled Jason
Farrell Sky News
well Jason is with me in the studio and
Jason allegations then about another
Force tonight and the Public's going to
be really concerned about this in London
and elsewhere in the country
um where does it all go next well first
of all this has been a day of reckoning
for the Metropolitan Police Force
they've been accused of institutional
misogyny racism and homophobia and
whilst the Met commissioner doesn't want
to necessarily attach the word
institutional to those failings he does
accept the diagnosis and he does seem to
accept most of the Cure that Louise
Casey is offering but he says it's going
to take time and that's what the Home
Secretary Sarah bravoman has also said
this is going to be a long road to
recovery but what Louise Casey is saying
in in this report that you've just heard
is that actually we need to broaden this
out we need to probe into other police
forces as well and if you read the KC
review and you look at the examples in
there
they are strikingly similar to what
we've heard from those two women in Hull
there are real parallels there and what
that would suggest is that this problem
this failing is far from contained to
one police force yeah we've certainly
not heard the at the end of it tonight
have we Jason thank you very much
now Russia's President Vladimir Putin
has said it's the West that is
continuing the war in Ukraine during a
summit with his Chinese counterpart
Putin said Moscow will react if the UK
sends depleted uranium ammunition to
Vladimir zelinski's troops well the UK
government said it would be providing
armor-piercing rounds for Challenger 2
tanks to Ukraine Skies Moscow
correspondent Dana magnet reports
[Music]
circumstance of a presidential
inauguration the big red carpet walk up
their AIDS lined up on either side two
men bent on restructuring the world
order and strengthening their ties
foreign
Putin especially this visit matters he
wants to project an image of grandeur of
one great power with another never mind
sanctions or war crimes indictments and
he needs China's support politically and
crucially economically
as for Ukraine he suggested it was the
West's time being prospects for peace
with a special mention for plans
outlined this week by the UK to supply
Kiev with shells containing depleted
uranium
[Applause]
and ideally
this is
present at today's meetings Russia's key
man on Military technical cooperation
and the defense minister but nothing
concrete on NATO concerns that China
might lend Military Support to we
haven't seen any proof that China is
delivering little weapons to Russia but
we have seen some signs that this has
been a request from Russia and that this
is an issue that is is
considered
in Beijing or by the Chinese authorities
president she was considering it he
certainly wasn't telling
already provides Russia with an economic
life
tools or with the narrative that he
shares with Russia that it is the flow
of Western weapons that are fueling this
conflict
sanctions have made Russia heavily
dependent on China energy flows are
going east at discounted prices and the
deal signed today suggests a lot of
other things will be too president XI
has little to lose and much to gain by
sticking with the status quo
Donna McNeese Sky News Moscow
back here and Boris Johnson will be
facing MPS on the Privileges committee
tomorrow over Danny Street parties
during covid restrictions the former
prime minister published his defense
today saying that he did not
intentionally mislead Parliament and
criticize the highly partisan tone and
content in the committee's damning
interim report our political
correspondent Ali fortiscu has been
looking at what he said
it was a scandal that helped bring down
a prime minister with an 80-seat
majority the birthday cake the suitcase
of booze it is recorded the cheese and
wine those fictional party was a
business meet
did Boris Johnson recklessly mislead
Parliament when he said this
all guidance was followed completely
during number 10. I repeat what I have
said to him that that I've been
repeatedly assured that the rules
after a long wait now we have this Boris
Johnson's defense a 50-page dossier in
it he effectively says he wasn't warned
at the time look at this I relied on
assurances I'd received from my advisors
and it's clear now those assurances were
wrong as prime minister I am reliant on
advice from officials his allies have
certainly rallied people do mislead the
house by accident you know you you
misspeak if you say you have to
understand uh every single nuance and
you're going to hold to a camp based on
new facts received and punished on that
basis ministers will simply come to the
dispatch box and say I can't possibly
comment we're going to have to have an
inquiry
the former prime minister also
effectively blames a number of officials
look at this he talks about a
conversation he had with jackdoll the
then director of communications he says
he jack Doyle explained to me that the
media team held a regular Friday evening
team meeting where they discuss what had
occurred during the week and have a
drink as this was the last Friday of the
Year there was also cheese and a secret
santa I asked him was it within the
rules he told me it was within the rules
but the committee investigating Boris
Johnson say none of this evidence is new
their initial report found that covid
raw breaches must have been obvious to
the prime minister at the time
he was the Prime Minister he was
responsible he wrote the rules and then
he didn't abide by them there's nobody
to blame but him
Boris Johnson says he wouldn't have
immortalized events with official photos
had he known that rules were being
broken
are you confident your evidence will
clear Mr Johnson
tomorrow he faces four hours of
questions in front of the committee
their verdict could see him suspended or
even losing his seat Ali fought skew Sky
News Westminster
and the former prime minister's evidence
will be put to the test tomorrow at 2PM
you can watch that session of the
Privileges committee as Boris Johnson
faces MP's questions over whether or not
he misled Parliament you can catch that
at two o'clock tomorrow live here on Sky
News
a man has been arrested on suspicion of
attempted murder after another man was
set on fire while walking home from a
mosque in Birmingham last night counts
terrorism police are now investigating
the incident along with West Midlands
police a warning that this report by
Becky Johnson shows the moment the man
was set on fire
on the bottom right of your screen you
can see an elderly man wearing black and
white has been stopped by the man who'll
go on to attack him he's trying to
continue on his way but the man pushes
him
now look to the left of your screen
as further down the street the elderly
man is set on fire
I saw when it was fired on down it all
happened outside monsor alam's house
before that my wife came
and if you get the water bucket of water
she brought some water out so did you
help put the fire out yeah she didn't do
it somebody else
another person helped him out take the
jacket out because the person went crazy
take his jacket he couldn't do you don't
know what to do he's running everywhere
he must have been terrifying the victim
had been walking home from this mosque
in Birmingham a man has since been
arrested on suspicion of attempted
murder counter-terror police are helping
with the investigation but officers
stress they're keeping an open mind
about the motive for the attack they are
however looking at a similar case where
an elderly man was set on fire outside a
mosque in London last month very quickly
we established there was a similar
attack with a similar modus operandi in
in London we've connected those two
cases and we're working closely with the
Metropolitan Police to see if those
incidents are linked councilor Sharon
Thompson knows the victim in Birmingham
and has been talking to his family he
was just walking home from the mosque
finishing his prayers so the whole
family is absolutely devastated and sure
traumatized and they're staying by their
dad's side which is understandable his
injuries aren't life-threatening but
they are serious this attack has left
people here asking why he was targeted
and if they're safe in their Community
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham
Thomas Cashman the man accused of
murdering nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
call Bell has given evidence in his own
trial this afternoon he told a cause he
had never ever encountered problems with
the alleged intended victim Joseph knee
Olivia was shot dead when a gunman burst
into her home in Liverpool in August
last year our crime correspondent Martin
brunt reports
Thomas Cashman was brought to court to
begin his defense of the murder charge
he denies
in the witness box Cashman said he was a
high-level cannabis dealer in Liverpool
making up to 5 000 pounds a week that
was before his arrest last year over the
murder of a young schoolgirl in her
family's home Olivia Pratt Corbell was
nine shot dead when a gunman chased
another man into the house and opened
fire the prosecution say Joseph knee was
the real Target a convicted drug dealer
he'd already been shot once before he
fled into Olivia's home
but Cashman told jurors Josephine and
his brothers were my friends for 10
years I've never had any problem with
Joseph or his family never they've
always been my friends
Cashman said he'd been with Joseph near
at his mother's house the day before and
denied scoping him out ahead of the
shooting
Cashman was also asked about a
prosecution witness a woman he'd had an
affair with she claimed he'd turned up
at her home after the shooting and said
I've done Joey Cashman told the jury he
didn't go to her house and he hadn't
confessed anything
the defense case continues in the
morning more evidence from Cashman then
he'll face questions from the prosecutor
Martin brunt Sky News Manchester
staff at a school which planned to
refuse entry to ofsted following the
death of their head teacher staged a
silent walkout today Ruth Perry who took
her own life in January was head teacher
at caversham Primary School in Reading
which was rated outstanding but
downgraded to inadequate following an
inspection in November skies at Matthew
Thompson has the story
her tragedy has sparked a teacher's
revolt
here at this school in Newbury just a
few miles from where Ruth Perry took her
life staff filed out in silent
solidarity
Ruth's family say she killed herself as
a direct result of a critical inspection
by ofsted the school's regulator
Liz a former teacher at Ruth's school
told us the inspection didn't reflect
reality
teachers were not leaving caversham
primary teachers were there for years
and years and years under Ruth's
headship and they were happy there and
they had a dedicated and caring and
expert her teacher and this is just
devastating and this is why we're here
for Ruth today
and another Community was left
devastated in 2015 when Carol Woodward
killed herself after ofsted downgraded
her school police told her inquest the
inspection was fair but its timing
during exams had contributed to immense
pressure on her over the phone Carol's
husband Roger told me about the impact
it had even though it was sort of six to
seven years ago it's almost as though it
was yesterday ofsted just put schools
under tremendous amount of pressure and
the head teacher obviously Bears the
brunt of it and in this sort of latest
scenario where she's being criticized
and like Carol said she she sort of felt
as though the whole school had been let
down
one concern in schools is the grading
system used by ofsted something that was
scrapped in Wales last year after a
review schools are very very complex
organizations so a grade is is
attempting to give a a kind of one word
judgment about a very complex
organization
the government said that inspections are
important for holding schools to account
the question is at what cost to teachers
Matthew Thompson Sky News Newbury
Gwyneth Paltrow has appeared in court in
the United States accused of being
involved in a hit and run ski crash in
2016. the actress's accuser claims he
sustained a brain injury and broke four
ribs in the Collision but miss Paltrow
says the man was to blame plaintiff said
these are my notes in his opening
she was dangerous and Reckless
she's skiing with her nine-year-old son
who's a beginner she is focused she is
not distracted
she got
taken out from behind
I mean that's what happened
and beavers will be reintroduced to
wetland in West London in a bid to
tackle climate change conservationists
hope the planned Wetland will promote
biodiversity in a similar project last
year two beavers called Justin and
Sigourney Beaver were introduced to a
farm in North London but the male Beaver
died before they could breed
now the prime minister's Windsor
framework is facing opposition ahead of
MPS voting Parliament tomorrow the
European research group of eurosceptic
conservative MPS described parts of the
brexit deal as practically useless
yesterday the Democratic unionist party
said that they could not support the
proposals scars political correspondent
Joe Pike reports and there's a nice
diagram on the back almost seven years
after the UK voted to leave the EU
battles over brexit are still not over
I'm going to make a brief statement as
today the ERG group of Tori Euro
Skeptics rubbish Rishi sunak's latest
deal EU law will still be Supreme in
Northern Ireland the Stormont break is
practically useless
and the framework itself has no exit
other than through a highly complex
legal process although they stop short
of saying they'd oppose it in Parliament
let's have wait till we've got our
meeting tomorrow in
Rishi sunax wins a framework was
intended to reduce checks on goods
between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland
at the heart of it the storm and break
if the break is pulled the UK government
will have a veto a mechanism to give the
Northern Ireland assembly more of a say
over how EU law applies in Northern
Ireland
but it's not enough for the influential
Democratic unionist party we're not in a
position to endorse The Windsor
framework that continued opposition
means Northern Ireland's assembly hasn't
sat for more than a year even though
most politicians outstormant back the
New Deal and some experts were impressed
by what the PM negotiated I was
surprised at some of the things they
have been able to secure I do think it
is a change from from where we have been
it does address many of the concerns and
I think if you look at the response from
businesses in Northern Ireland generally
they're welcomed and been been
optimistic about the benefits
we'll have to wait until tomorrow
afternoon to see the size of the
Rebellion here in Parliament to see
whether members of the ERG abstain or
vote against the government and indeed
to see whether they move on block but if
there are a small number of rebels let's
say 10 to 20 MPS that won't just be a
relief for Rishi sunach it would also
perhaps suggest the ERG are now a bit of
a spent Force labor support will
guarantee a government win in the
Commons but at Stormont power sharing
still seems a Long Way Away Joe Pike Sky
News